in five four three two one
welcome everybody to another episode of
the genius brain podcast you know what
[ __ ] it on this one we're just gonna get
straight to the topic because every time
I do that I [ __ ] forget let's do it
man
yes so on the patreon we have a lot of
people who have first dibs on topics and
questions and when it comes especially
when it comes to advice that they want
us to answer and I thought it was just
dope just to kind of you know freestyle
some advice for you guys so let's do it
the only way you can ask though is if
you become a patreon members so make
sure you sign up and apathy on make it
pop in and happen so this message came
from Cesar Ortega a patreon member hey
David and Joe I don't feel like I have
many to talk to right now so I figure
I'd vent to you right now I'm in a
relationship with this great girl
and I know I want a future with her
right now however I'm in California with
my family after living in Houston for
three years but I go back to California
I'm going to school and working towards
a nursing career but it's so hard to
find motivation to continue going to
school while being separated from my
girlfriend I just know that I want to
take care of my career so that I can
support my girl and get that job that I
find really fulfilling and I know that
helping people as a nurse is super
fulfilling but damn I feel so stagnant
right now I'm 20 years old working as a
certified nurse's aide and going to
school to get my bachelor's in nursing
and damn it feels like I am on a routine
the job is great but school just doesn't
feel as gratifying it just makes me
question why I'm schooling if it doesn't
make me happy if it doesn't make me
happy
it just feels like a chore well I've
said what I had to say um oh and I think
I want to find another route even though
I know it won't be the secure as secure
as a job I have now living with my
parents feels like I'm not my own person
and fee and I feel like I'm being
treated by my parents as if I'm still a
little kid and I can't make decisions
for myself and it's annoying I'm sure
there's a better way of saying this but
it's frustrating not being able to live
the life I want it because I'm still
under their house so and I still have to
follow the rules and I am over it every
time I talk to a young person yeah I
want to [ __ ] choke them and be like
you [ __ ] and I
and I love and I love this guy because
he reminds me of me when I was his age
and yeah I think like the problem that
we all have when we're younger is we
don't know how to prioritize our
thoughts yeah yeah because to me the
simple solution is you know your ticket
out of all of this is when you get your
bachelor's and you start working as a
nurse yeah
it's just the time right yeah so like I
always tell people like when you're when
you're going through school when you're
working on your degree when you're going
before you have your career and all that
it's not supposed to be fulfilling
because that's what you're supposed to
be doing it's training when is training
ever gonna like make you feel fulfilled
make you feel accomplished make you feel
happy like you're not even there yet
you're practicing you're still at the
point of practice so like when you're
like judging your life right now and
being like oh I'm not fulfilled and
happy with what I'm doing it's not it's
like duffle you're practicing yeah and I
think just reading from what from what
you said you already don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on in your head because
you said a couple of things that
juxtapose what you were saying you said
I'm working towards a career that's very
fulfilling and then in the latter half
of the message you said Nursing is not
fulfilling so again I want to find
something that's not 9 of like it's like
what are you saying full um you know
it's one of those things where it's like
he's probably like well nursing will pay
the bills and I can probably like work 3
or 4 days out of the week because they
have really dope schedules and I can
take care of my girl and I can do this
so he's really balancing it all out if I
could go back and tell myself do not
make any don't meet in the middle for
[ __ ] yeah like if I wanted to pursue JK
I should have just went a hundred
percent and I shouldn't have been like
well I need to get a career first and I
needed to do this first and I needed it
like it's it's fine I have a game plan
but we all kind of know what we really
really want but we talk ourselves out of
it is what I'm saying and definitively
what is what is fulfilling for you like
what what does fulfillment mean because
the other part that's kind of disturbing
about what you said is that you it seems
that you wanted to complete this job and
have a good good living for
or girlfriend first of all you're 20
[ __ ] years old why'd you have to take
care of her you should exactly you
should not be looking forward to to have
a job at in career to make money to take
care of your [ __ ] girlfriend but
David that [ __ ] so good
he can't stop thinking about it man
nothing is as exciting as that [ __ ]
that's exactly what he say he's like oh
man like I can't see her until I go to
Houston but I'm here in California life
is so boring
of course it's bored cuz you're not
[ __ ] dude yeah yeah I think right now
like your dick is getting in the way of
your [ __ ] brain because you're you're
talking about this this this nursing
career that you're doing is very hard to
do because you're spending most your
energy and time thinking and missing
missing your [ __ ] girlfriend yeah
like this is a problem that a lot of
young people have and I say this because
I'm also saying this to my young self we
invest our time into other people rather
than investing it into ourselves but we
don't know how yeah we don't know what
that means yeah [ __ ] my dick so
[ __ ] lonely right now yeah I mean for
you Cesar
if your mind already is that you are
doing this career for to provide for
somebody else it already doesn't make
sense because your personal career
should be for yourself or use yeah so I
don't really understand how that logic
works and like Joe said I think you
understand what's great about nursing is
because of those quote unquote flexible
hours you work three days a week but
they're twelve hour shifts and that's
kind of what entices you to kind of go
and pursue that career because I
understand what you'll get in the end of
it but of course all the stuff that
you're gonna do up into that point is
gonna be boring not all the [ __ ] is
[ __ ] easy yeah you know even even for
example like the stuff that we did on
you too when we first started off man
this [ __ ] made no [ __ ] money bro yeah
it wasn't fulfilling in that way yeah if
he was fulfilling to the soul what not
when the video didn't do well not win
the [ __ ] computer crash and we have
to re-edit the video yeah not when you
[ __ ] post a video and only three
people see that [ __ ] you know like it's
not gonna be the greatest so like I
always tell people there's like when
you're going toward the goal that you
want learn to look so far [ __ ] ahead
that whatever you're dealing with right
now you you're like fine so like he's
like
no respect in the home fine that should
be motivation for you to hurry up and
get this damn degree stop [ __ ]
bullshitting around and then become a
nurse and start making that money
because nurses get like paid [ __ ]
good and you can move out and who gives
a [ __ ] if they treat you like a kid
you're not to see them anymore just deal
with it it's only a year or two and
here's the other thing too what you
can't have your cake and eat it too and
what I mean by that is you can't live
under somebody else's roof rent [ __ ]
free eating all the food using all the
toiletries yeah using everything and the
thing you want to treat you good yeah
and then you want them and you want to
be an independent human being yeah it
doesn't work that way you cannot have
your cake and eat it too I see this a
lot I mean Cesar obviously Ortega you're
not you're not Asian but there's a lot
of Asian kids that I've heard so many
times talk about the [ __ ] they go I'm an
independent person I'm an adult really
you're not though because they should
carry you because you're still sucking
on your dad's dick and your mom's tit
so you're not really that independent
yeah I wasn't independent yeah you want
to be treated as an individual yeah but
when they financially support you you
know they are the ones putting money
into your bank they could treat you
whatever way they want that's the
control that you get so if you really
don't want that then yeah you can move
out I don't think it's [ __ ] smart I
save the money man just go through the
headache save the money I'll tell you
this man if my parents were still gonna
like me too I would oh my god I would
pay them a little bit of rent to help
them out around the house I would just
hear them [ __ ] nag at me all day but
I would save a [ __ ] ton of money and
work towards my future if someone's
gonna cook for me clean for me [ __ ]
listen to me complain I will listen to
them complain and I will listen to their
[ __ ] stupid joke suggestions all day
long
yep just so I can be rent [ __ ] free
yeah I don't think you realize too as an
adult oh is this your phone down
goddamnit so alright now now it's back
to two uncles bitching out Cesar yeah so
when you're an adult I don't think you
realize how expensive it is to be
independent right so you're 20 years old
When I was your age too I used to think
that I wanted all this independence and
which I did
and I did get for myself but I also
forgot how much it cost ya to be on my
[ __ ] own how much that weight of
responsibility is to carry that [ __ ] on
your shoulders yeah but good for him
though he's a he's a certified nurse's
assistant at at 20 kickin I was still
jacking off and dreaming of being the
biggest drug dealer in California at 20
years old I was a piece of [ __ ] you're
more of a man than I was at twenty
twenty years old your [ __ ] you got a
legit job you have a licensed you're a
licensed professional you know like he's
probably making like 15 bucks an hour
more than I [ __ ] did at 20 years old
so good for you you just have to deal
with you just gotta you just gonna have
to deal with [ __ ] but just
understand that it's temporary in one or
two years is not that much time and it's
just gonna make you tougher so use this
time to just motivate yourself like you
know what imma [ __ ] get I'm gonna be a
nurse like I'm gonna have my own place
I'm a [ __ ] in this living room I'm
[ __ ] in that [ __ ] shower right
there we're gonna be all over the house
I'm a mover over here from Houston you
know she's gonna pursue her dreams and
[ __ ] we're gonna be awesome just to go
back to what I was saying before like
you really do I'm not telling you this
just so you as if I could do any better
than you what I'm saying is that in your
case you really do have to take a step
back and start thinking about doing
things for yourself first especially at
your age yeah cuz the fact that you said
that you're doing this for your
girlfriend for me anyways is it's a
little alarming because I'm not saying
y'all are gonna break up I'm not saying
that [ __ ] but [ __ ] you're 20
years old
that [ __ ] is a pasta [ __ ] ability but
he loves her so much wants to take care
of her and show her that he's a man and
he could provide man because he's
already talking about marriage right
that's how that's how good or [ __ ] is
because he's like I got a [ __ ] lock
this [ __ ] in before anybody else gets
this I'll tell you this man I had a
buddy of mine who before he went to the
military he was with the girl loved her
to death even took care of her kid a lot
and I think that kid looked at him being
called him dad and [ __ ] and everything
too and he specifically went into the
military because of the military
benefits and what he could do for her
and that kid right signed up decided to
go into the middle
and lo and behold he got in and started
doing it and as it was continuing he was
gonna bring them with them yeah
the [ __ ] broke up with him yeah while
he was whatever not in in training or
whatever right and he was getting things
set up where he was gonna get paid and I
think you get paid more if you have like
a dependent under you and [ __ ] like that
yeah and she broke up with him because
she didn't want to be with him and she
did that after he left well I think
that's the problem with a lot of guys is
we have this imagination of how the
world is gonna be and and and we don't
communicate right so that's a big
problem is like you know we don't sit
down and actually ask them hey do you
want to get married you want to do this
whatever like it's more like it's more
like I want this I want it to be true
yeah I wonder if you even had a
conversation with your girlfriend about
this too like do you tell her straight
up a [ __ ] night I'm out here in
California and I do this [ __ ] for you
I'm pretty sure that's not what you know
I'm out here in California I'm [ __ ]
doing this [ __ ] for you [ __ ] Boonton
like I'm [ __ ] out here just being a
nursing [ __ ]
like are you saying that to her and
she's okay with that she's like thank
you baby thank you so much for being a
nursery is that the type of relationship
that you have cuz I think in a healthy
relationship somebody wouldn't want you
to base your career on you know for them
cuz she I'm pretty sure she's a
grown-ass woman
why can't she have a career how come she
can't support you a little bit yeah how
come she can't be a nurse too and you
guys could nurse together at the same
hospital yeah and there's each other's
feelings of [ __ ] ya make double the
income that's a [ __ ] ton of money man
hell yeah
dude when I see what I know just make
good [ __ ] money yeah and this is
another good topic to get into we always
talk about this where I think people
make a big mistake about trying to check
all their boxes with one thing in their
life Yeah right
specifically a lot of people do that
with their careers they think that their
career supposed to be soul-satisfying
make you a [ __ ] ton of money fix your
marriage do all the stuff for you right
but it's not a remedy for one thing you
have to learn how to compartmentalize
what you want in life with different
things right cuz I think just recently I
used to do that I thought okay well if I
work on my career here as long as my
career's [ __ ] dope and tight it'll
everything else will just fall into
place yeah it doesn't work that way like
I have to develop other parts of myself
too and it'll get better on its own
balance it's all balanced because I
thought that okay if I'm making a lot of
[ __ ] money then what other worries do
I have yeah but that wasn't true the
when I may be most amount of money when
I was when I thought that would solve
everything for me because I grew up so
poor it didn't fix [ __ ] it was when
you're in a sadist I was the fattest and
I was the saddest fattest instead I was
so fat I was so [ __ ] sad and I didn't
know what to do with myself because I
thought that if I made all this money it
would create leisure and would create
time for me to spend with my girlfriend
and also their stuff and it really
didn't it didn't fix [ __ ] yeah cuz I was
trying to check off my happiness box
with one [ __ ] thing when really I
think humans are really complicated and
we need a lot of different activities
and we need to fulfill ourselves with
different things yeah that's true man
and I think everyone's at that stage
around 20 is like oh I gotta choose my
life's destiny what's my purpose what's
my passion you know I I mean I had the
hardest time choosing my major I
probably switched my major like five
times oh for sure because I was like oh
[ __ ] I started thinking about like my
future and and how my life was gonna be
if I choose this career than this and
that and it's it's kind of scary because
there's just so many things to think
about you can't predict and it almost
feels like you can't control your own
life yeah so he's probably sitting there
like oh man like what if this doesn't
work out and then will I become a nurse
and then like I don't like it and then
like I want to find something that I do
and passionate about or whatever but I
would say like just everyone's got to be
responsible for the decisions that they
make that means like make the decision
and be okay if it doesn't turn out the
way that you wanted it to it's just a
way towards something yeah and and and
don't you know expect too much from it
yeah the only thing you should expect
from your career is that it pays you and
it takes care of you you know and it's
not going against your morals and maybe
you know if it if it makes you feel like
fulfilled then great but not everyone
gets that luxury of balancing out
fulfillment purpose great money all that
[ __ ] cuz like especially at 20 like
you're [ __ ] you're lucky as hell that
you get a job that pays you
bucks an hour right but how the [ __ ] is
that gonna fulfill you like especially
if you're doing [ __ ] like data entry the
entry is like I'm putting [ __ ] on an
excel sheet numbers [ __ ] letters
words how the [ __ ] do I find purpose
behind that I'm not supposed to I'm
supposed to pay the bills you know like
and there's a lot of people that are
like oh I don't know what the purpose is
in [ __ ] stapling papers it's like
you're not supposed to the purpose is
you're learning how to [ __ ] work cuz
you're a [ __ ] loser and you never
worked a day in your life and you're
learning work skills
yeah and it's a stepping stone you
[ __ ] yeah like God a lot of people
too who have great jobs but they find
their fulfillment on their weekends when
they spend it with their family or they
go hiking and they do like Spartan runs
or whatever yeah and that's the part
that fulfills there's other part of
their life that the career doesn't you
know you're putting a lot of pressure in
yourself too it's like oh this doesn't
feel as fulfilling and it's you know
you're 20 years old man you're gonna go
through these feelings all the time
specifically when you're doing the
boring parts of where you want to go
because that's the struggle and
everything right and you know just
anything in life you guys already know
this some of the things with the biggest
amount of rewards have these shittiest
roads to get oh hell yeah man it it it
takes time to develop at that stuff and
right now you're sad because your girl's
not there dude yeah everybody would be
sad if they're not getting their dicks
relationships suck this podcast is
brought to you by purple my friends if
you have never have never had a good
night's sleep in your life I guarantee
is probably because of that crap crap
mattress you're sleeping on well my
friends that's because you've never
graced and blessed your body with the
purple mattress I've had my purple
mattress for a minute right now and I
got to say something guys best sleep
I've ever had I've had a lot of back
issues in my life because for some
reason I was told by an old Asian lady
that's sleeping on a bed that's made of
rocks age-old history hey dirt and pain
was the way to go but the purple
mattress my friends is made with rocket
science involved yes the technology
behind it involves some rocket science
it's cold and cool and warm at the same
time kind of a crazy thought
right but it keeps you cool but it keeps
you warm at the same time it's just
right it kind of relieves all the
pressure points in my body because it's
not one of those weird spring mattresses
and my friends if you want a purple
mattress I got to tell you that's not a
better time than right now you're going
to love purple and right now my
listeners will get a free purple pillow
with the purchase of a mattress that's
in addition to the great free gifts
they're offering site-wide just takes
brain to eight four - eight eight eight
the only way to get this free pillow is
a text brain - eight four - eight eight
eight that's be are a I n two eight four
eight eight eight have you had a yeah I
was with Jess oh that's right for long
distance that was rough yeah because you
don't have access to the person yeah and
you get to see them like once a month if
you're lucky maybe once every two months
or something and you don't even get to
see him for a long time but I do have to
say that there's something awesome about
that because every time you see them
it's very special oh it's like I've seen
it was so long every single time so and
then when we started to live with each
other like that magic disappeared yeah
so we're not excited to see each other
so things are gonna change like just
coming from a long-distance relationship
to living with each other man is a huge
difference so you might be thinking like
every time I see hurts it's bliss and we
[ __ ] like bunnies and like we every
time it's like an awesome date because
you're always on vacation yeah but when
you mix school work stress paying bills
living together
[ __ ] snoring and oh man you're
naughty
just honestly prolong the lot of the
long distance as long as possible well I
had a long-distance relationship and I
think I could relate the Caesar a lot
specifically because I was roughly
around his age 18 19 when I had a
long-distance relationship and I was
just like him to us I'm oh my god like I
would talk to her every [ __ ] night
like a [ __ ] loser
waste her time and we would just sit
there on the phone cuz we missed each
other what do you do yeah
be what are you doing exactly just like
four or [ __ ] five am excited up this
is so dumb
and and during those times too is when I
didn't really develop who I was
yeah I just put my time and love and
effort into this release this
long-distance relationship I worried
about what she was doing I wanted to her
to be next to me all this other [ __ ] and
from [ __ ] one man because it feels
good yeah but it goes away though oh
yeah yeah it really does and those were
the times that I feel like I wasted a
lot of energy
on people on people and specifically her
and who knows man maybe if if I wasn't
such a loser at the time maybe she
wasn't such a [ __ ] loser at the time
maybe we still would have been together
it's a part of growing up for real yeah
but there's a balance right I wish
someone was there to tell me like quit
[ __ ] [ __ ] around you know and
jacking off on the phone listening to a
voice longer why are you breathing so
heavy baby just keep talking shut the
[ __ ] up no they would moan for me like
reading a bug oh yeah high-pitched and
[ __ ] make that noise and I like a lot
are you breathing so heavy oh my god but
it's so stupid cuz if someone told me
hey quit [ __ ] with your dick and you
could get the real thing if you just
hurry up and become successful and
she'll [ __ ] you can fly her over
every week it doesn't matter
oh for sure - yeah I think that's that's
one of the positive if I could look at
the the long-distance relationship thing
like you said the the the time I did get
to see my girlfriend when I was away
always felt special yeah it was like it
was like that brand-new butterfly
feeling yeah every single time it's very
intense do you feel like when you are
with Jess that was kind of like the
foundation of what you thought was going
to happen when you when she came here -
yeah it was supposed to feel like that
all the time yeah I thought it was gonna
be a vacation all the time you know yeah
and and it was gonna be awesome but that
was a very unrealistic idea of what
reality was but I mean you know like I'm
delusional dude
I'm well III just believe a lot of [ __ ]
that I think that I want to believe
sometimes and then I'm like oh it's
gonna be vacation all the time and it
probably could have been that way if we
didn't [ __ ] fight so much yeah if we
learned how to solve our issues quicker
and we learned how to like just just
move on it would have been better but it
was a bad recipe for that yeah yeah cool
well seize or take I hope you like that
one we got another one from should we do
a lady or was that a boy yes that was a
boy that was a boy boy Oh she'd do a
lady one let's do a lady one I got this
guy he won't [ __ ] me oh that used to be
a stir fields there'll be so many
girlfriends like my boyfriend doesn't
[ __ ] me enough and I'm like girl what I
look what kind of guys are you dating
and how why is there so many women that
are like my god my boyfriend doesn't
[ __ ] me well you know I always wondered
too when I when I you know when I hear
that type of [ __ ] is well how shitty is
your guys communication oh did you ask
him did you the answer you or do you
expect him to always make a [ __ ] move
did you grab his dick and start sucking
it yeah pretty sure if you grab his dick
he's not gonna be like babe come on stop
right you know I think and if he did
though that's we hear there's a lot of
people too who just expect things that
happen especially when it comes to
[ __ ] in a relationship they like
girls who are a little more timid with
their emotions and feelings and they
feel that even till this day when
they're an adult that sex is something
that's naughty they always expect the
guy to make a move but the guy has to
come up and touch hurt and grab a start
kissing her neck but sometimes for a guy
they're just you know they're waiting
for you to make a move yeah and then if
you're the person that's always shy and
you're the person that's always pushing
back after a while the guys were like oh
maybe she doesn't want to [ __ ] all the
time oh yeah I'm that way because I I
only like to hunt so much and then if I
don't feel that that back I feel like
I'm a rapist yeah and I'm like I'm the
only one that's always wanting to [ __ ]
like I feel like a weird horn dog and
then I'm not even sure if she wants it I
had a relation too but we had a long
talk about um it was it was kind of in
that situation where I said I don't
always want to be the one to always have
to ask you for sex Yeah right because if
you want sex you
have to speak up yeah right because
there can't be a moment where it's just
like hey we haven't really had sex
they're all like sexually frustrated and
[ __ ] it's like why don't you [ __ ]
tell me up and down yes because I also
just don't like being told no all the
time right and then I can't read your
mind and figure out when you want sex
especially when I when when it's always
in the cards are in your hand to always
say no because if you ask me to [ __ ] I
will never ever say no I don't i mean i
could be doing open-heart surgery I
would leave the scalpel in the [ __ ]
heart we'll go [ __ ] that come back and
I'll figure it out later
you heard of him so it's definitely not
my problem it's not me not wanting to
have sex like with that specific girl
because she grew up I think thinking sex
was such a dirty thing yeah she felt
weird asking for sex and so she wanted
Jesus lot yeah
no really that's what it was like oh I
don't feel really comfortable with it
it's like well I don't really feel
comfortable being shot down 50% of the
time yeah it's it's a touchy subject man
yeah yeah and I always say like kudos to
the guys out there that that can date a
girl that has a weird relationship with
the whole that topic yeah I like hoes
dude straight [ __ ] girls that do just
they're so comfortable with themselves
like I just because it makes me
uncomfortable when someone's so
uncomfortable yeah cuz I'm just like you
know loosen up you know and I don't want
to be the one that's like I don't like
this whole guidance thing I like equals
yeah because if some guys like that cuz
they're like oh you know like I know
[ __ ] I'm the [ __ ] master I can
show you the world for me I'm like I
don't want to [ __ ] a virgin
I want a [ __ ] you want some damn
experience I want yeah because like I
want to get past that and see how we can
connect sexually and what we can provide
for each other
yeah so it's old me it's almost like
like you don't want to play basketball
with a child yeah you want to play with
someone who's gonna give you something
back energy-wise and you want to be able
to discover together so not that like
inexperienced people can't but they have
to be at least comfortable or have a
healthy relationship because I don't
want to guide them through it and I
think that's the way girls feel about
like virgin guys right
don't want to guide this nerd they want
a man that's gonna yeah it's hardest
it's a definite like uphill battle
because for me I've always I like
messing around with girls who were Lucic
women but I never wanted to develop a
relationship where girls were too loose
but really I think it's because maybe
it's good because the girls that I
[ __ ] around with I think they were
just damaged women oh you got it like at
that time like I always said to and I
used to do this understand a bit it was
like I used to say you must have you
must have gone through some [ __ ] to have
found a man like an Asian dude in
flip-flops and socks with an anime
t-shirt it'd be like I want to suck that
dick yeah you must be going through some
serious [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god you know
and I look back at those women I go you
know what thank you for making me feel
special
it really did take one for the team like
III appreciate you for [ __ ] touching
me cuz I look back at those photos and
I'm like damn dude you just really
didn't want to get [ __ ] I mean girls
don't go for looks I mean I I'm gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] her that no I mean like I
think a lot of girls get some girls get
turned on by really interesting things
like energy and like a connection and
like like you know like Mickey like
she's like all guys are sexless to me
until they make me laugh that's so
[ __ ] she's like once a man makes me
laugh she was like oh it makes sense
though you know shoutout to Nicki but we
saw what you look like before you look
like hot trash so whatever girl that you
know you got with BAE they're pretty now
but they look like [ __ ] before something
and they're still in that my maybe huh
yeah I don't know but those girls were
great man like I really do want to thank
you do for making me feel special for
that one night it's like damn dude cuz
you know that YouTube dick was gonna get
you a oh that [ __ ] wasn't gonna get you
[ __ ] you're just like you know what
David you make me laugh for tonight yes
like that dick so funny yeah what was
the girl's question yeah so here we have
from well she doesn't have a real name
we out can you address the importance of
being vulnerable with your significant
other I feel like the generation I'm in
doesn't understand that concept also
address the fact that you don't become
smaller by asking for forgiveness it
kind of falls into the same subject I
don't think it's a generation thing I
think people in general
don't even know what that word is or
don't even know how to be vulnerable I
think your generation right now you guys
are the most vulnerable they're more
vulnerable than ours
yeah I've seen so many dudes cry in
front of me now when I was younger man I
never saw a [ __ ] male adult cry
yeah I didn't we start crying they'll be
like shut up you [ __ ]
yeah it's like why you cry do my mom
called me a [ __ ] because I think
[ __ ] cry difference I feel like in
our generation if a guy cried in front
of us we'd stop being his friend yo so
in this podcast I might have but we know
this guy but when his win is dad passed
away I I just stopped being his friend
but he it was kind of weird that he
asked us to come out and be with him
after his dad passed away cuz it was
like a really vulnerable time like maybe
you should like collect yourself a bit
yeah and then you know you could really
talk to us a little more but there was
there was two people who oh I did tell
us I told us on the Cristino on a
Christina podcast but when Chris was on
but basically what happened was at the
end of it I kind of just I just went I
just kind of his back really awkwardly
twice I was like you'll be better and
that's all I could do cuz I wasn't used
to comforting somebody crying like that
that wasn't my [ __ ] you know so cuz cuz
for me if I'm going through some stuff
right I would cry it out first
and then if I talk to you and a tear
comes out that's that's an after effect
of really dealing with my emotions it's
cuz we get it we is cuz we talk to each
other when we're actually looking for a
solution so we could figure it out yeah
I don't just go and cry just not right
like I could I could cry just to cry by
myself and then I'll go ask advice for
solutions yeah that's how we handle [ __ ]
though yeah I think that's our
generation or just the way that we deal
with [ __ ] cuz if I'm gonna waste your
time I wanna be ready to do something
about it I don't want to [ __ ] waste
your time and then waste your time and
then waste your time over the same [ __ ]
and drive you crazy yeah cuz that's how
I take it when people do the same [ __ ]
and I'm like you cried about the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] for the fifth time I'm not
listening to you anymore that makes me a
bad friend maybe I don't know but I
don't like that yeah I like it because I
feel disrespected I'm like hey I'm
giving you my time
I'm giving you my support and what I
think you should be doing cuz you're
asking me questions and if you don't use
it that's fine but don't ask me ever
again yeah cuz you I already gave you
the answer that means you weren't
listening yeah so was that an [ __ ]
yeah some people just vent just to vent
right and I'm getting better at that but
I think that's because that's the type
of people we are we just like a man
don't [ __ ] waste our time and shut
the [ __ ] up yeah and I think too just
for her if you're having problems with
this with other people opening up and
being vulnerable it's also very hard for
people to be vulnerable because a lot of
people don't want to do that because
they're afraid of getting hurt because
when you open yourselves up and you get
shut down when you decided to open
yourselves up to this human being and
that person gets [ __ ] diced and
sliced up it's like yo [ __ ] I made a
mistake I should have just shut my [ __ ]
yeah and that's what people are scared
of because being vulnerable yet it does
open up a relationship and help it to
grow but you that person also has to be
willing to take that risk
cuz there is a risk this podcast is
brought to you by native my friends have
you ever walked around smelling like
crap that's probably because you're not
using deodorant
well the deodorant of my choice my
friends is native and native got that
fresh fresh good scent and not only do
they smell good and they keep you
smelling fresh because I've been on the
eucalyptus and mint and that lavender
scent it comes without aluminum's
parabens and talc and it's filled with
stuff found in nature such as coconut
oil shea butter tapioca starch it's
never tested on animals and there's free
shipping and returns um gotta say guys
love it love it love it love the sense
is and for me to like especially because
I do a lot of sports and I travel a lot
deodorant is is something that I have to
use consistently and native is a very
very good deodorant to use it doesn't
have any funky or weird smells to it and
I like the fact that it's paraben free
and you guys no parabens any any product
with parabens potentially bad for you so
I definitely like the way that they're
on with that so check it out mm-hmm for
20% off your first purchase visit native
deodorant calm and
use promo code gb during the checkout
that's once again for 20% off your first
purchase visit native deodorant calm and
use promo code gb during the check out
my friends uh like I said I actually
really do like this deodorant give it a
go and if you're not big into like those
you know crazy weird name sense um and
these are like sense that you know that
you generally know the smell of and you
know that it smells good and it keeps
you staying fresh all day so I use it a
lot it's dope give it a try yeah
whenever I look at a situation ever I
never say you should be more vulnerable
yeah because I'm not creating an
environment for them to open up yeah so
you know yeah there are people that are
very closed off but people tend to
confined in you or like though they'll
open up when they feel comfortable yeah
most people don't because they don't
feel comfortable yeah so a lot of the
times people don't setup the right
environment for for people to be able to
speak freely yeah and if you're talking
about this in a relationship sense yeah
I mean being vulnerable with your
partner is very very important um and if
somebody finds that as a sign of
weakness you you would be very much
mistaken because being vulnerable with
your partner helps it to grow a lot
there's there are the things that you
should really open up and communicate
with your partner in my personal opinion
because who else will be there for you
yeah like who else if the person that
you're gonna spend the rest of your life
with that you're too if you're in a
monogamous relationship if that person
can't be there for you in that type of
sense then who like who they're supposed
to be your confidant they're gonna be
your family they're gonna be a wife or a
husband and vulnerability is something
that you should be selective of but it
should be something that you should be
able to do with the partner that you're
with because things can only get better
from that point yeah you might get hurt
you might feel like you made a mistake
when that [ __ ] backfires in your face
here and there but if you do have a
healthy relationship and you guys are
communicating really well their
vulnerability is a [ __ ] must I don't
think in most cases two people know that
they're holding information back mmm
like you know like most people
they don't go through our life like
hiding [ __ ] like they're not doing it on
purpose no it's like we all see it
because people are stupid and we see
what they're doing but we have this
funny thing called ego that protects us
from seeing ourselves so like you might
see your boyfriend
um hurt over something and then you're
like talk to me about it and then he's
all like I ain't heard what the [ __ ]
what are you talking about
yeah they don't even know they don't
even know they don't know that they
something just bothered them mm maybe
you got a word it different maybe it's
like he doesn't like to be called hurt
even though that is what's happening but
when you want someone to be vulnerable
with you you gotta use their words and
things that make them comfortable
instead of saying no you need to say it
like me mm-hmm in admit that you're hurt
and be open and vulnerable like that'll
never open people up yeah it's and I
understand what it's like to not want to
be open and vulnerable with somebody
because in a previous podcast when I
first started this podcast I'm Ariel on
I told her that's something that she
didn't know but I had a huge issue of
saying of showing her that I missed her
or kind of being more affectionate
towards her because I just had this
weird roadblock a fear of like well what
if you [ __ ] leave so what's the woman
showing you the side to me anyways you
know there's there's fear to that type
of [ __ ] especially and it depends on you
know what stage of your relationship you
are with this person cuz it took me like
three years for me to finally open up
and really be vulnerable with her it
could be and you have to even know that
you had that fear yeah it took a while
for me to kind of register this because
most people will just react mm-hmm and
then just be like oh I can make maybe
crack a joke instead of saying I miss
you or whatever right until someone
points it out and they're like what oh
oh I was because it would be on some
[ __ ] like if I if I kind of said like
hey I really missed you and I appreciate
you this [ __ ]
would be in a bunch of a group of our
friends you know what David said
yesterday he said he really [ __ ]
[ __ ] like dope that's between us what
would you do that damn is so funny [ __ ]
I just opened up to you you [ __ ]
but it's because she thinks it's really
cute yeah and she she finds it really
adorable but she wants to parade it
around like a trophy yeah like she feels
great like this is an awesome thing and
I understand it I'm just like she's
gonna be an awesome mom just
embarrassing the [ __ ] out of her kid you
know what little little King King said
King King said that he loves his teddy
bear he's like oh god you just
embarrassed her son first I renamed him
King King so he's already in a baby ok
little kinky little kaing kaing did yeah
I think everyone should learn to be a
little more vulnerable though but in
order to for that to happen it takes a
lot of courage in it and what what I
mean by courage is being able to look
inside and this is some next-level
maturity [ __ ] where a lot of people
can't even do it and they're like 60 or
70 oh do men you would think through
some of these old people man you would
think that the moment they try to even
say something is cute or adorable you
would think that they would have a
[ __ ] heart attack yeah cuz up because
it's not manly enough right like even
saying like for example like my dad has
never said sorry if that fool said sorry
I think he would have a heart attack you
know it's like I'm sorry
never say sarkodie never say sorry dude
they never will yeah and it's because it
makes you vulnerable you I make them
lose yeah makes them wrong oh yeah I
think all the Asian people just hate
[ __ ] losing and being wrong no
mistakes no mistakes whatsoever I think
my dad could literally like place a bed
of knives upright on the floor trip me
and have me landing it and he'll be like
you should have just been born with a
steel body you know you should have
looked where you were walking huh you
should do the shrimp turn your body
sideways and missed all the knives like
that's just how that man is like it's
implying you should have continued
Taekwondo if you were in there but still
a pad you'd be pets past it like a cat
and then you jump on your feet look at
this one okay my mom too
she said this funny thing did your mom
is your mom involving more than your dad
it seems like I think my dad has a ball
past my mom really my mom is the most
stubborn human being oh [ __ ]
she she's so [ __ ] stubborn she says
she goes all the things that you hate
about me that I do don't even think
about changing it because I will never
change Wow yeah she goes you be an adult
and you live with it for the rest of
your life she's odd
she's very self-aware she's very so she
knows she's a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah she
just was like no this is how mommy is
you either accept it or don't accept it
I'm not gonna change me I'm like okay
well I guess I just have to deal with
that then
because for example like this woman
cannot keep a secret to save her life
she still can't do it yeah and I keep
falling for the trap I'm the dumb one
yeah like you could you could tell me
I'm not gonna tell anybody I'm like this
my mom I could trust her a few seconds
later she goes I told everybody she's
probably like I'm not gonna tell nobody
and she goes out of her way to start
calling people up instead of like you
know when people slip at a secret it's
like could during a conversation yeah
your mom probably intentionally calls
people up and lets them know your secret
dude verbatim what she said in Korean
she goes I feel that if I don't tell
somebody I'm going to internally explode
from guilt from like because she just
can't hold a secret she just has to tell
somebody I mean you are the worst person
ever if I ever commit a crime she is not
allowed to be there as a witness she
will I have to tell you David killed
that person she he cared him so bad and
all the crimes that you did in the past
all of it my mom is such a unique person
like I think I'm very grateful to have
because at least I could talk to her
very casually and very fun I didn't
realize how uncommon my relationship
with my mom is I mean yeah especially in
a Asian household where like how close
you guys are yeah like we talked about
everything yeah I mean like Meryl I got
into a little fight yesterday and I
talked to her this morning about it just
a vent yeah and then I felt way better
yeah and my mom too whenever she fights
with my dad she calls me up and she
[ __ ] about this full this she called
me up the other day dude about my dad
she goes god damn your dad did it again
I'm like what am i what did our dad do
she goes you know how he just [ __ ]
acts like he's just a smartest
[ __ ] person on earth Wow and
every time I do something wrong he goes
oh you don't even know how to do that
she's like [ __ ] you
I don't need a douche yeah she goes well
there's a lot of [ __ ] that he doesn't
know how to [ __ ] do he goes how many
times have I told about the price of
that product and he's always asked Oh
how much is it how much is it what are
you [ __ ] dumb he's just stupid - and
then she's literally talking [ __ ] about
him as he's sitting right next to her
Wow and he doesn't give a [ __ ] my dad's
just in the background like your mom's
at it again and I could hear him just
mouthing off in the back and she's
talking [ __ ] about him to me on the
phone as he's sitting next to it dude
they have some passionate fights there
huh dude they're old they still fight
super passion I mean not as bad as it
used to be when I was younger but they
still get into it they still fight it's
because they work together 24 [ __ ] 7
still they still run the business
together damn they see each other right
when they wake up all the way to the
till they sleep they don't have a break
from each other so you think that's a
pretty good that's a pretty bad idea huh
mom-and-pop shops I I think that it is
more friends make it work
yeah I don't know how they [ __ ] do it
though yes I think if I work with Muriel
every day she and I not will not be
together um we're just too headstrong
people and I I can't do it maybe it's
like you know how these couples are set
up I I think I feel like if if what you
get out of each other is different like
for example like maybe you and Muriel
like you guys get get out of a lot of
things in life that's like you're
compatible in like philosophy and life
and your morals yeah and maybe like how
you have fun but then your career
directions totally different and how you
do work is totally different so maybe
that that's why it might not work out
but then you guys are so well and all
these other things and then some of our
friends I think it's like maybe their
careers and things align yeah it goes
the same way especially in terms of
creativity she and I are very different
so that's where we butt heads a lot like
things that I find funny she really
doesn't yeah funny so if you notice our
friends they complement each other they
don't get in each other's ways yeah cuz
you and Mary are very artistic yeah so
you might conflict in things that matter
whereas like like some of our friends
it's like they work in the same business
but they don't step on each other's like
like yeah passions yeah like one is like
I don't give a [ __ ] about the money part
you handle the money part yeah and
that's all he does and engine and he's
like I don't even give a damn about the
employees and that's all she does yeah
you know yeah they just kind of know
their roles very well and I think Meryl
and I don't have that like we had this
thing of for example just like
decorating the place right yeah I want
to decorate it a certain way and usually
within a relationship and this is funny
I just you're both very visual see
that's why you step on yeah yeah so we
have this thing of we just talked about
this yesterday where I was like the
reason why it's hard for us to live
together and be in a specific place is
because we both want to say in the same
things mmm cuz I think normally for a
guy when it comes to a place like you
just let the girl decorate and then you
just come and live there now I'm like I
don't give a [ __ ]
pick whatever you want and makes you
happy cuz but for me I [ __ ] hate her
taste oh she wants to decorate something
no I don't want you a decoration because
I don't like your taste I think it's
gonna look terrible like I think it's
gonna look trashy ouch
and I mean you did a great job on this
place though it looks pretty chill it's
cozy
yeah it's modern you don't want it to be
modern but but still kind of like
originally I why this place it looked
like looking Bali dude so when you come
in oh yeah it's got a tropical vibe a
little bit yeah and I only did it like
20% cuz I was like I'm not gonna leave
it forever so yeah because just you know
started adding up money-wise yeah
because I wanted to add a lot more
plants like different types of art a
different rug yeah and just start doing
a bunch of wicker wicker baskets and
different like type of clay pots and
[ __ ] but then I thought to like I don't
really live here so what's the point man
that was me too that's why my projects
all took a halt
yeah I was like if I'm not yeah I'm not
gonna spend more money on this but
exactly so I I kind of just that's where
she and I clash a lot of [ __ ] we're just
hyper opinionated about the stuff that
we both like when there's usually one
person we'll handle this and the other
person will handle that but we both want
to stay in everything and that's the
problem you got a pic into your battles
oh for sure if she and I were uh like
doing a YouTube together we would be two
months later this is why we broke up the
video title the video that was like this
is why we broke up and then we would
have to do the whole video because we
just wouldn't get along in that sense
that's rough yeah yeah you got it you
got to know I mean it's good that you
knew that [ __ ] right I mean that's you
you already saw it come
so that's why you didn't do it yeah
whereas like I'm stubborn where I
wouldn't see that and go nah we could
change and that's why I'm not with you
yeah it's hard man
like I think I got a small taste of it
when I originally for hints her
Instagram I started an Instagram for her
oh [ __ ] yeah I started that Instagram up
for her and then I I think I tried to
work with her on it and it just didn't
happen it was we would just clash and so
um because originally she just wanted me
to handle it like take photos and an
upload it for her and then she would do
the captions but you know just dial and
taste she didn't like it she didn't like
the way I would take photos or anything
like that so I'm like okay if you don't
like it then just you do it yourself
which I was fine with it you know but
that's just an example of us not that
was the taste of Oh like she really does
she really does want to say and creative
and it's not just like her just to have
an account as a business move to connect
with fans it's like oh no like I really
want this to be a part of myself and
represent Who I am so I'm like oh then
it's not going to work so that's good
you backed off though that would have
been like but and that's why we fought
cuz um you know and I don't know that's
just the way we probably did a lot of
things is how no is when you think that
you know better than someone you're like
ah you don't know yeah you know I have
that problem and let them be yeah I mean
you obviously did it cuz you and Mario
you were able to give her space yeah I
mean I in my mind I was like I know
better than you but I just had to let it
go I'm gonna fight no more I just don't
want to fight anymore I just had just
hate fighting it just drains me man it
takes my spirit out yeah it [ __ ] it's
literally if she and I fight it
literally feels like the next day
somebody just took this vacuum opened up
my chest and sucked up my spirit I know
and I just sit there just I can't work
right I can't do [ __ ] oh I thought was
me for the last several years that's for
me for like three four years yeah I mean
it was rough man like it's it's just
especially cuz when she and I were first
together man you know how much she and I
fought man I think we used to have the
[ __ ] that the bro bitching days
[ __ ] what yakitori spot to be like
this [ __ ] yeah I think that's how every
sentence started with this [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah but we all moved past it
see that's cool cuz you guys got over
that and now it's a different and in
like you guys bicker or fight but it's
never explosive and [ __ ] up like it
used to be no oh yeah so now you can
focus on your career in your I mean it's
all showing to like you know you're
doing way more now now and it's like
once that veil is lifted you have more
mental capacity to just operate you know
well well guys that's the end of this
podcast I hoped we helped both you out
with your issues and your problems I
know it sounds like we're a little harsh
at first but there's always gems in
there man like Caesar if we could just
reflect back on it you're doing really
well for somebody who's a 20 year old
and has already worked towards your
career you're way past anything that I
personally was doing at your age I was
still singing Boyz II Men songs about a
girl who dumped me
and Joe was over here [ __ ] yep doing
absolutely nothing my friend nothing
yeah and well it was her name we we out
yeah or hidden name cuz she doesn't want
to be known hey why don't you be
vulnerable and tell the world your name
girl what the hell trying to tell other
people to be vulnerable but um all jokes
aside I think it's awesome that you
brought that up I think you know it's
not just this generation but everyone
should be a little more vulnerable with
each other and and be stronger and being
okay if people hurt you
yeah it's okay that's what makes us all
stronger as we go through the pain all
right you guys well you can find us on
if you guys like this section if you're
watching this video write in the
comments below that you wanted to do
more advice topics because I personally
love it cuz it opens up a lot of
conversation topics for us so yeah catch
us on Spotify iTunes stitcher all that
other all that other audio platformers
we are out there give us that five star
like share comment everything people
because genius brain is out there to be
the best podcast out there in the world
best
all right y'all we see y'all next time
peace happy